you know the normalization deals that
have emerged in recent years the
abrahamic Accords
have been talked about as though they're
like groundbreaking new
um
phenomenon but many Arab countries have
normalized relations with the Israeli
regime
um since the birth of the state it's not
a new thing
um but yes he I think he was talking
about Egypt and Jordan at the time today
we can include
United Arab Emirates we could include
Bahrain we could include Morocco
um
and you know these again these abrahamic
Accords they are promoted
and marketed and talked about as some
kind of like religious uh
reconciliation which I think is the most
disgusting thing ever because they're
not about religious reconciliation
they're about arms deals and economic
deals and they're about
you know consolidating power and the
reason they're about Mutual strategic
interests that all of these nations have
together and some people argue that you
know
Palestine is no longer an Arab cause
because our Arab countries are
normalizing but most of these governance
if not all actually all these
governments that have normalized most of
them are monarchies
um are not elected governments and they
do not
um represent the will of the people or
the desires or the opinions of their
peoples and the proof to this is like
places like Jordan
and
Egypt even though they've normalized and
had peace agreements with Israel for
many many many years
Palestine and the Palestinian cause was
still a talking point in the political
campaigning of politicians with
Jordanian Egyptian politicians and
continues to be
um for them to gain popularity because
that's where the hearts of the people
are
um
and then you know the Zionist regime is
quite explanatory the Imperial Zionist
regime I mean what else do you call a
regime that sought help from
Imperials powers to depopulate an entire
country and build a new one on top of it
so mostly you say the thing
that Abraham records achieved is a
is a negative thing for Palestine
so these kinds of agreements amongst the
power uh about the uh between the
leadership is not uh yeah it's not
positive for for the region no no
obviously they're going to be marketed
as as positive and obviously another
they're gonna
have this flowery language surrounding
them and and the idiots in the room
might like nod and smile but anybody
with critical thinking skills can know
that if a people continue to be under
occupation you know that's there's
nothing positive there and it's also
there's you know let's linger a little
bit on the mutual interests the only way
Morocco could normalize relations with
the Israeli regime
is
so that the Israeli regime could
recognize Moroccan sovereignty over in
the western Sahara
which just happened actually last week
and now Morocco uh and before that
Morocco recognized uh Sovereign Israeli
sovereignty over the West Bank it's not
like Morocco itself is just has no
interest in this kind of uh deal